ouverture à metz du procès du meurtrier
présumé de deux garçons âgés de 8 ans le
procès de patrick s'est ouvert à huis
clos devant la cour décide inhalent
jeune homme avait 16 ans au moment des
faits arrêté sept mois plus tard il
avait avoué avant de se rétracter à metz
jean-jacques bâtir en début d'audience
nous avons pu apercevoir qu un jeune
homme m'a spall mes cheveux roux
s'asseoir dans le box des accusés
à quelques mètres de lui les pièces à
conviction deux vélos de cross avec
lesquelles s'amuser
les enfants le jour du meurtre ainsi que
cinq grosses pierres les armes du crime
ensuite la porte du palais de justice
s'est refermé sur un procès qui débute
deux ans après l'arrestation de patrick
deux années pendant lesquelles il a
souvent changé d'avis dans un premier
temps il avoue le double meurtre et
donne plusieurs détails édifiant puis
ensuite se rétracte estimant avoir
craqué devant les policiers
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on le questionne sur
ses premiers aveux il reste silencieux
ne donne aucune explication sur les
fameux détails
aujourd'hui les douze experts ont
commencé à faire part de leurs
conclusions seront ensuite 40 témoins
puis le rapport des policiers qui ont
recueilli les premiers aveux de patrick
un moment qui sera certainement l'un des
points forts de ce procès prévu en
principe sur quatre jours